uh my name is
Ravi and I'm going to give my
introduction a bit later if hopefully
that's okay with everyone uh because it
would make more sense I guess towards
stand that's what I wanted to say uh
today I wanted to talk about a topic
which I think sometime gets overlooked
in machine learning is the hidden
technical depth in machine learning and
I will try to Showcase how me and my
team has tried to kind of handle it uh
so yeah let's get into it I would say so
let's start with the story right like
stories are always nice at least for me
so let's start with a story basically
story of me uh a little early in my
career I would say where I joined as a
data scientist at a subscription based
company and uh I was very excited to be
honest I was a bit overconfident and I
didn't Knew Too Much so but I I was very
confident so and I was tasked with this
uh churn model which is very classical
thing so I was very confident I was like
yeah I know all the algorithms I have
worked with them so much it should be a
easy thing and I mean I could produce
result very fast get onto it with
quickly and yeah maybe impress my boss
at that point of time and uh yeah and it
should be easy for me to just like
create something get it running and
maybe as I move forward I can streamline
it make it better and I was so excited
just to start with it right when you're
new in career you want to do those
things uh so I started where everybody
would start like my trusty Jupiter
notebook that's where I started started
with my data analysis preparation did
all the mugging with the data and
everything data preparation uh I I was
like I know there is imbalance in the
class I was taking care of those so the
basic thing things which youc counted in
the machine learning I was like yeah I
can handle those I did the model
training I did the validation and I was
like yeah this looks good and I was like
getting happier and happier uh and then
the question was like can you put it to
production I didn't know much but I
looked around I'm like yeah sure I can
do that so what I did at that point of
time was something like this where I was
and this were like manual steps in a
Jupiter notebook where I was extracting
my data
from our database doing all the
preparation training evaluation all of
those in Jupiter notebook now I was like
I have to put into the production so
basically I used my train model the
model I was very happy with which had
all the good good score and then I
looked up online and I was like maybe I
can because we were on AWS at that point
of time so I was like maybe I can use uh
lambra which was like new and exciting
thing at that point of time uh and I was
so what I did basically was create a
Lambda function uh using the runtime um
which is at that part I think it was
psyit learn so I used that runtime to
support it and wrote everything the
Handler function for it in Python and it
was at that time I was very proud of it
because uh it was pretty good for me at
that point of time where it could uh
react to an event um get the model file
deserialize it make it into a model
object used the data which was sent by
the event object and produce the
prediction and serve it and I was like
damn I'm good like you can see where I'm
going right I was so clueless at that
point so I was like yeah my code is in
production maybe I can move to a
different project I already put it into
production so it should be nice and fine
and yeah everything is automated so I
don't need to do anything I can maybe
start with the segmentation project I
wanted to do for some time and that's
where the the things started not looking
good
right uh I spent a lot of days drinking
a lot of coffees I don't know how much
caffeine I had in my system at that
point of time but the very first thing
which came like to me is like I got some
feed Frack from the business I went and
I tried to change some feature because
we had a plan uh which changed so we had
two tier plan which changed into three
tier PL I wanted to change the feature
and that changed everything because as
you know in machine learning you change
anything you basically change everything
and if you look at the core of machine
learning model it's a it's it's
basically a machine for mixing different
signal to predict something and when you
have so much signal mixing each signal
is kind of dependent upon each other so
there is no inter they are so
interdependent there is nothing which is
totally independent and that's commonly
known as intag liit so that was the
first time I saw that uh I was getting
over that and then I was like oh I have
so many chunk feature because i' like I
tried so many model and I guess some of
you might have seen where you create
like 10 different version of your
notebook where you try different things
and sometimes some of the old junk
feature which might not be that valuable
gets into your uh model and now you're
like not sure where you did it why you
did it and I like and the whole data
depends why I added which table it's
coming from so that was another thing I
was trying to figure these things out
and then I realized okay I did change
something in my development pipeline
which I forgot to push to production and
now you're kind of feeling Ravi is like
a really bad data scientist I was not or
I was maybe but then I realized I
didn't do it so like the good result I
was getting in Dev was not getting
replicated in production and that is
very commonly known and you might have
heard of it as the training service skew
right so I'm like still figuring it out
this data and everything and because I
have automated everything I had lot of
configuration issues because I did
something looking it up on the internet
trying to fix it and now a lot of those
configuration were not making sense for
me and I had multiple configuration
issues because of that and then I use a
lot of glue code because you're like
okay I want to have my data from this
place but I want to push it to S3 but
also I want to use Lambda so you end
using a lot of glue code because that's
the fastest way for you to move ahead
with this and that's what I did uh at
that point of time thinking that okay
that might be a good thing to do right
but as you know in machine learning it's
not always good to move so fast because
like the technical depth it has been
there for some time and it has been used
very often in software engineering but
in software engineering when we are
working with technical depth what we do
is like we go back we refactor our code
we change some settings and it's usually
easier because you have like all your
code in a GitHub and you have
proper not that much interactions among
the code but in machine learning it's
more difficult because it it has so many
moving parts and sometime we forget that
machine learning is not just about your
algorithm or the code around it it's
much more complex than that and when we
try to move fast we keep on building
this technical depth and then you have
to spend a lot of time trying to fix
these things and this is not actually
like adding a new feature you're just
trying to optimize your current state
because when you want to scale you want
it to be cost efficient because at the
end of the day business wants everything
to be cost efficient even though how
great it is if it's not cost efficient
most probably that project would get
killed uh this I didn't understand start
of my career right uh slowly this was a
tough learning but but slowly I
understood and I want to share this
picture uh which makes a lot of sense
now so when we think of a ml system your
ml code is one of the smallest part of
it right uh the bigger part which I
think we all have heard thousand time is
like a data scientist spends 80% of
their time working with like data so you
take your data data verification feature
engineering and I kind of disagree I
don't think it's 80% there are much more
places where we put more time to it uh
that would be like testing our model
doing all the checking all the metadata
of our model doing the different Process
Management doing analysis between
different version of the model or
different sets of the model and then
when you finally are ready to put into
production then a big heavy load of
configuration comes right you have so
many configuration for your serving
phase for your training phase and all
those thing if you're doing
hyperparameter tuning then you want to
automate this uh you also have lot of
resource management because you don't
have all the resp resources at your
disposal do you want to spin up more
CPUs do you want to spin up more gpus or
do you want to scale up you want to
scale down what would be your serving
infrastructure at that point of time so
these things right and you also want to
monitor because like if anything is in
production you want to have a pulse of
how things are moving you just don't
want to leave it there uh and these adds
a lot of things on top of it and one
thing which I think has now becoming
more and more prevalent as we are moving
ahead are basically these three things
right security is obviously makes sense
but also the legal compliance it really
doesn't matter which part of the world
you're living in I I'm based out of
Europe so we have lot of compliances we
have to follow when we are working with
machine learning so you have to make
sure that whatever you're building is
compliant otherwise you can get into lot
of trouble and it's not just because
there is is a law you have to do it as a
person or as a company we also has this
ethical thing where we should be
transparent about how our model is
deciding what it is deciding because
sometime the output of a model could
decide a fate of a human being whether
it's a insurance company or anything
else so you should be very clear you
should have things set up in a place
which could showcase this right and you
can very clearly explain and if you see
biases you can go and improve
it great so I talked a lot about what
are the problems right let let let me
talk you through how hopefully we can
manage it or how I have been and my team
has been trying to manage these
things uh
so let's let me quickly start my leisure
pointer so that easier for me to
explain awesome so I think this this
whole topic like having a good data
platform I can can speak about it for
like an hour because that's the base of
everything if you don't have a good data
platform any machine learning you do
would be garbage this has been like the
case since the Inception of machine
learning right so first make sure you
have a good data platform where your you
are sure of the quality of data and
everything and then once you have this
data platform this will take care of the
stuff which I talked about in the
previous the problem I faced right the
data dependency so if I go to DBT I can
see the different references I can see
the lineage I can see how each uh
feature in my model where is it coming
from has it chain in the past so these
kind of having a good data platform can
help you a lot with the data
dependencies and it's and it's a very
important component of a machine
learning infrastructure which I feel
sometime gets overlooked uh then I mean
we we're still doing our initial data
analysis in Jupiter which is good tool
to be honest like if you are at a very
early stage trying to figure out things
trying to play with it notebook is a
great environment where you can still go
and run a small block see how it's
outputting but once you are ready with
your notebook what we are trying to do
is like a good way to do would be to
automate your workflow and one way to do
this would be using flight so I'm not
here trying to push everybody to use
flight but I'm just sharing my
experience this has worked best for us
uh given our scenario maybe something
else for you because there are lot of
good tools out there so you have to
evaluate for yourself so what we have
tried to do here is uh
basically create Docker image for each
of the flight tasks so uh this would be
[Music]
my one Docker image running one flight
task in DBT which would do my data prep
and because it's in DBT I can see the
lineage and everything once the data
prep is done I can have my python which
I'm very comfortable with running in a
separate flight task again a Docker
image and then you can R have another
image running your evaluation and
validation right and this whole workflow
you can have a workflow config uh where
you can Define this and flight has this
great feature where you can par
parameterize your workflow so even if
you have to change your workflow here
and there are small changes uh it can be
done using parameter which is a great
way to do uh and this makes the whole
taking tracking your config ation much
easier uh flight also provides us with a
great uh UI where I can see the whole
workflow and I can do some input and
output validation so that works good for
us and yeah you can have like multiple
workflow running and one of the good uh
Advantage following this approach is
that even if you have worked with python
you know that setting on the environment
is a night me right you get a code from
your colleague and you try to run it and
then you figure out oh this version of
python does doesn't support this version
of this package for and those kind of
things but if you have your registry
created for Docker where you have
already uploaded that image they can
download image and can get started
working it with quite fast and you can
take care of those dependency there once
you're ready with your workflow once you
feel like okay this is the best uh
output of a model uh you can save it at
a model registry again it's up to you
which model registry suits best for my
case it's a simple s three where we are
putting all our models the train models
and once you know this is like okay this
is great and obviously because it's like
everything is in Python code everything
is parameterized and it's it's easier
for me to work with kit so I can have
the Version Control on top of it which
makes it easy for me to look at my code
get peer reviews because like when
you're working alone you might Overlook
some stuff but because it's a code it's
on git you can ask for PRS and reviews
that makes the chances of error less
obviously not foolproof but that makes
it easier to understand and once you
have that ready you can have a very
separate uh workflow for your production
so you not hampering your production
workflow which would again be something
like a different flight workflow and
same way the containers right so you
will have the feature engineering part
of it done one of your flight tasks
could load your artifacts and once
you're done you can use any serving
architecture you want like here I have
given example of Selden code but it's up
to you which one you want and basically
from there you can serve your model and
here like some of the things I talked
about earlier about uh like the whole
configuration issue and this it makes it
a bit manageable because you can set the
templates you can set the uh standards
for this uh workflows and that you can
share across the organization and you
can work with
it um and then I think one of the
important part which is like the whole
communication if you can set up event
bus among them so that they have a
standard way of communicating between
task that would be a great help here in
any case and I think one of the most
important which like as a data scientist
you would appreciate a lot is setting up
those uh tracking so having a matric
dashboard where you can see the
different Matrix related to your
algorithm U it could be depending upon
your algorithm Roc curve or like me
error or all those things and using
something like homeo for logs and
resource monitoring so you can see okay
how much resource we have using what are
the different logs so if a configuration
is failing now it's easier because you
have the locks so you can go to that
locks and check and fix those issue and
then you can set some set up some
monitoring uh with a tool like a data
dog where you can see has my pipeline
been working or was there a delay in the
data pipeline or was some error and
these all tools the they provide great
graphical user interface so it's easier
for you to daily go and check and when
you want to go into details you can go
into the logs and get the more detail
about it so this like this gives
you quite a good place to start with it
and I mean you can never get rid of the
technical depth but it keep makes you
more prepared to handle those as they
come and be like you can minimize it to
the most and the way we have we are
trying to also do it is like all of this
containers I talked about doer they are
orchestrate using kubernetes so again
it's in code so you can have those code
in GitHub you can review this code and
basically it's much easier to maintain
than everybody running their own system
and for kubernetes and we are using
terraform as our basically orchestration
of our infrastructure right so it's a
infrastructure as a code so it's easier
for one team to share this code with
other team where they can replicate and
the code is again so having these kind
of approach where you're not kind of
working inside a tool but at a code
level uh provides much more control over
things uh and when you think you are
ready with all of this and you are ready
to move to multiple ml project one great
thing for anybody to look would be to
have a feature store uh feature store
basically will help you a lot with the
initial things we talked about like the
training serving skills or in tag
liament because once a data science team
has created a feature for the model and
they know that it's good they can put it
into feature store and there are
multiple feature store in the market or
you can use your own where it provides
like the same copy for your analysis and
also for development so the chances of
Sor not development sorry production so
the chances of training and servy queue
reduces and most of the feature store
nowadays also have this thin layer of
high velocity database so when you are
working at a real time it all always
stores the latest feature value for that
feature and that could be accessed
within millisecond so you can have
real-time prediction which could be a
challenging if you want to fetch that
data from a database and then it on top
of it obviously had more feature and it
it kind of provides this a common place
where as a data scientist when you're
starting with things you know these are
the feature created by some of the data
scientist in your team and you can reuse
them so you don't have to worry about
like making those pipeline again and
working towards it so you have something
already there and it makes you move
faster uh one more thing which I want to
say here is like because you have this
nice monitoring and you can see all the
loggings you can Implement different
things for like heuristic explanation
and fairness these are the things I
talked about during the ethical part
right you want to have some kind of
heuristic measures you don't just want
to say this is my mean error or this you
also want to talk to business and say
like like my model has this percent
error is it good enough and just
checking with the business you should
have some kind of uh framework like
sapply or anything where you can explain
your model and given that this is quite
automated infrastructure you can run it
put those graphs into one of your
dashboard so people can see how the
model is performing and then you can put
a human in the loop where a domain
expert could sit and see those graphs
and maybe say that okay this is not
making sense and not and blah blah blah
basically and that's how you control the
ethic parts of it right or uh and then
one thing I'm was really not sure how to
put into it but I give it wanted to give
a shout out is to use a tool like a
carpenter in one of your like that would
come here which could provide you like
Auto scaling so when you are doing
hyperparameter tuning you can Auto scale
or upscale your workflow to use more GPU
and then when you had find out those
nice parameter you can downscale to like
so suppose you upscale to 20 GPU because
you're hyper parameter you know you can
down scale to again like 2 GPU and then
you're saving cost but you're also
saving time so these kind of thing if
you keep on mind when you're designing
about your infrastructure could actually
really help you I would
say so uh coming to the moral of the
story drink a lot of water yeah I I was
so dehydrated with all the coffee so one
thing would obviously drink a lot of
water another thing like making
shortcuts because sometime you want to
just start with things taking shortcut
would actually impact your project worse
than taking the time initially to think
about everything so think about those
thing at the start uh and it's very
difficult for anybody to say how you
would quantify this technical depth and
just moving fast doesn't mean you're
doing it right uh you have to carefully
see what are the areas where you can
fail and think continuously over it if
you are working in different like Sprint
or if you're working in quarters you
have to put some time into refining your
process or looking into technical depth
you can't put all the time just into
adding new feature you also have to
improve currently improve on new feature
one of the paper by Google I have linked
to it uh at the end of the presentation
has very nicely mentioned that some of
the guidelines you can see to do this is
like how easy it is for you to test a
new algorithm on a large scale right so
if you have the kind of workflow you can
most probably run it very easily U again
data like make sure you have a pretty
good data platform set up uh and
basically if you are going to change one
part of your system can you measure how
it's going to impact the other because
as I mentioned earlier everything is
quite linked and finally is like
improving one model should not
negatively affect the other because
sometime one model could be input to
your another model so you try to improve
one model but it kind of so you should
be able to see that and those kind of
Matrix dashboard and the threshold that
provides you a very powerful tool to do
those things so yeah and how easy for
you to get a new team members get up and
running and it's easier to explain your
code where is the code and all those
things yes I think that was what I
wanted to talk about I have added the
links to the papers which I would
recommend and some books uh you should
read because I think this problem is
very specific to each organization and
each problem so choose the solution
which works best for you uh and yeah
this is me I'm working as head of data
analytics at sead it's a big company in
NAIC if you outside NAIC I'm not sure
you know about it I worked as a data
scientist at HBO uh before that tell2
and I've been working with data for last
13 years and yeah now the stage is all
yours to ask me any question I'm really
looking forward to hearing from you guys
if you have fa similar challenges or
what are your things I would hang around
in the conference even after the talk if
you have anything please reach out or if
you have a question let me
know Robie that was awesome and perfect
timing you left uh a mere five minutes
for any questions I see a few right here
in Q&A it looks like there might be some
in the general chat um we can kind of
start there and obviously anyone who's
listening if you have additional
questions or as you get answered and um
again you think of anything feel free to
post them in the Q&A we can and we can
pull them from there
[Music]
I see there are two questions on the
chat at
least yeah we can dive into them within
next four minutes we got yeah uh so I
think the first one is in managing
technical depth slid some of the tools
logo aren't captioned can you please
tell which tools there are yeah sure so
like the idea for me is not to tell you
which tool to use uh but to give you an
idea there are tools so I can most
probably let me go back to that slide
and uh basically explain what those
were uh wait this is I have to click
through it quickly so that yeah so in
terms of logging you have grafana which
you can use as a metrix dashboard then
homeo we use homeo for our resource
management and logs and everything and
then you have data dog which we also use
quite a lot uh for monitoring our
services how they are running and
everything is working fine but I also
want to stress again that I'm not saying
these are the only tools you can use
there are multiple tools the idea is
that you should have metric dashboard
you should have those logs you should
have monitoring in this place doesn't
matter which tool you use if that makes
sense
good should I move to the next one why
flight instead of
airflow yes let's do that yes so I think
like if you go to flight website they
have a pretty good uh blog post about it
but I will try to go over briefly in
this so flight is made for your data
pipelines and orchestrating that uh
sorry airf flow but flight is made for
orchestrating your ml workflow so it is
I would say more polish to handle those
things and it provides some of those
feature where it is easier for you to
build those pipelines and work with
Dockers images and make it work better
because flight is uh much more focused
on machine learning I would say and
airflow I would say for your data flow
so I think both tools are great and they
actually work great together so don't
think of one as a replacement of other
they are complimenting
tools
yep
awesome um with the next two minutes
again if anyone has any further
questions um or if there's anything
again they can we can always continue
this conversation in Discord they're
also via link available in the reception
area um and just a heads up that we are
recording all of these talks so they
will be published soon and you should
get notified um when they do go live if
you want to rewatch but Robie again
appreciate you greatly for the
presentation I found it super helpful
I'm sure everyone else did um but yeah
with the next 60 seconds if there's any
closing remarks we can go from
there no I mean like I want to learn
from what you guys have been fishing so
I would hang around in the lounge area
and like the I would be here in the
conference event tomorrow so I'm happy
to hear your thoughts and like what you
are facing so and happy to present
thanks a lot for giving me this
opportunity